un viaje a Rusia por la paz según
durante esta visita oficial de tres días
el presidente chino y su homólogo ruso
Vladimir Putin plantean la eventual
resolución del conflicto en Ucrania como
eje central el 24 de febrero Beijing
propuso un plan en 12 puntos para
alcanzar la paz y este lunes Rusia se
dijo abierta a dialogar
[Música]
sin duda debatiremos todas estas
cuestiones
incluidas sus iniciativas que tratamos
con respeto Por supuesto
a lo largo del conflicto que deben
respetarse la soberanía y la integridad
territorial de todos sus países y pide
la protección de los civiles en su
propuesta sin embargo sigue sin estar
claros y simpatiza con las
reivindicaciones de Moscú hemos visto
que el plan de paz pide efectivamente un
alto al fuego que garantizaría a Rusia
la ocupación de grandes franjas de
territorio ucraniano con más tierra de
Ucrania de la que tenían al entrar en la
guerra
Estados Unidos ha advertido que no
suministre armas a Rusia algo que ha
planteado como una posibilidad y hoy
expresó nuevamente su escepticismo ante
la propuesta china el mundo no debe
dejarse engañar por ningún movimiento
táctico de Rusia apoyada por China o
cualquier otro país para congelar la
guerra en sus propios términos
posturas similares han adoptado la
reunión Europea y la otan subrayando que
china se ha abstenido de condenar a
Rusia por su invasión de su lado quiebre
reafirmó el lunes que la rendición o La
retirada de las tropas rusas del
territorio Ucrania no tienen que ser
condiciones previas para que pueda
aplicarse el plan de paz chino